Island executive is still not up and
running which is an astonishing
extraordinary situation you're the
Northern Ireland secretary do you accept
responsibility or some responsibility
for this failure
um no I think we are trying to find the
solutions to the problems and uh the one
of the reasons the main reason that the
Democratic unionist party left the uh
the executive and remember we are here
the backdrop behind me is Queens
University Belfast where we are marking
the 25th anniversary of the Belfast Good
Friday agreement which set up the
institutions many institutions one of
the one of the most key ones being the
Stormont the executive uh having mlas
elected and Stormont is run on a very
different basis to many other
legislators across the world because of
the unique circumstances in Northern
Ireland but it's on the principle of
consent you need the consent of both
communities to get it up and running in
the pasture and feign
um have collapsed dormant this time it's
the Democratic unionist party and they
were concerned about the impact of the
Northern Ireland protocol
um I was having here and I'd like to
Think Through The Windsor framework we
have managed to solve a number the vast
number of those issues and now we're
talking to the Democratic Universe party
and Eunice communities about getting
their politicians back into Power
sharing because that's what is required
here to for the smooth and effective
delivery of public services and
um and here in Northern Ireland public
services are more challenged in just
about every other place in the United
Kingdom you say that the dep aren't
prepared to enter power sharing because
of the protocol
some would argue that actually that's
effectively a fig leaf that the real
reason they don't want to get it back
into Power sharing is because they can't
stomach the idea of a first Minister
from shimfang do you think that's the
real truth
um well certainly I've heard so Jeffrey
Donaldson say absolutely categorically
and I've got no reason to disbelieve him
but that is definitely not the case
um and um and I've spoken to a whole
host of as you would expect dup mlas and
others from the uni from unions
community no that that's I I truly
believe that is not the reason so it's
because they think that the brexit deal
is bad
um I I well what they would like to see
and we we've had this discussion on
panels uh here over the last couple of
days I believe what the dep would like
to see is a restatement by the
government of the United Kingdom about
the importance and the position
of Northern Ireland is an integral part
of the United Kingdom and that's
something I'd like to think I I have
done here and the Prime Minister will do
later today now honestly like taking a
political sort of speak away
how close or how far do you think the
dep are from re-entering Power sharing
what is going on in the conversations
and how optimistic are you uh I mean I
mean that's a really difficult one
because
um I I I'm now but I'm now waiting to
hear uh back from the Democratic
Universe party as to exactly what they
would like us to do as a UK government
to uh to kind of restate what we are
doing here the Northern Ireland is an
integral part of the United Kingdom
based on the Belfast Good Friday
agreement uh where we're marking the
25th anniversary here today and will
remain so unless the people of Northern
Ireland want to change that no
politician whose words or or views can
can change that so
um I think you'll find that the
government of the United Kingdom is very
keen and happy to restate how important
it is that and we are how proud We Are
of having Northern Ireland as part of
the United Kingdom but waiting for a
democratic unions Party friend
and colleagues to tell us how they would
like that to be to be stated so we can
do it properly because I'm Keen just as
everybody else is to get to get the the
institutions here up and running I mean
I have to admit that you know if it was
all as simple as just the UK government
saying that we're happy and proud for
Northern Ireland to be part of the Union
I'm sure it would have been fixed by now
it feels to me like actually there's
much more thorny and difficult issues at
stake like the role of the European
courts that in Northern Ireland for
example at what point do you say look
this is not working I'm going to call
another election
um well I've actually I do have the
power to call an election here in
Northern I don't think it would be
helpful at this stage and I have that I
have that power all the way through to
the uh to early 2024.
um so but I to me that is the kind of
the ultimate uh backstop and it's not
something I'd be Keen to do everybody
tells me here that it would just
polarize the situation
um across Society uh more uh than it is
polarized now and that's not what that's
that's not an aim uh that I have or or
the government has so we we want the
institutions up and running
um we've heard some good words from
Jeffrey Donald Jeffrey Thompson a former
MP who is a high-ranking
MLA Emma little Bengali here at this
conference and I truly believe that we
can get there
um remember it wasn't that long ago that
the Windsor framework
became public as it were and was adopted
it was less than a month ago that it was
actually voted on in the House of
Commons and went through the joint
committee and there's a there's a lot of
there's an awful lot in in the Windsor
framework took a lot of negotiation and
so that's why we've tried to give as
much time and space
um to the to the unions communities and
their political representatives to
digest all that
but I like to think we are getting to
the point where that is you know that is
being well understood that negotiation
between the UK and the EU is over it's
all about implementation and
demonstrating that it does exactly what
it says it does you said this week the
ongoing cellmate installment was the
single biggest threat to the Union what
do you mean by that
yeah so
um so this is one of the uh
Stormont the the executive and the uh
the mlas are one of the key Parts the
key part of the Belfast Good Friday
agreement having I'd like to think that
what we've been able to deliver with the
Windsor framework which does put uh
Northern Ireland in a in a unique
position within our uh Union
um helps guarantee Northern Ireland as
part of our Union for a very long time
uh to come and I think when people do
not see their institutions up and
running
and public services are falling back
with compared with the rest of the
United Kingdom then they start to wonder
whether whether that institution is
worth having and actually at the end of
the day
um maybe uh you know look to other
places to try and deliver or maybe
believe that another constitutional
setup will deliver those Services we're
not in that space so are you effectively
think then that you know frustration
with storm one frustration parts of the
DP in particular could push people to
supporting a United Island what is
happening here is that you know we've
got local elections in Northern Ireland
that uh a tiny bit later than in the in
the rest of the United Kingdom on May
the 18th
um there'll be an interesting test of of
local opinion but you know unionist
communities should be comfortable and in
knowing that they that the the
government of the United Kingdom wants
them to remain a a strong part of our
United Kingdom for as long as they want
to the only thing that can change that
um is uh the people the voices uh you
know the votes of the people of Northern
Ireland
um in the future so they are in complete
control of their own destiny so I
actually think you know the union is is
a strong how as it's ever been and going
to get stronger through what we've
managed to deliver through the Windsor
framework and what I'm trying to say is
that now we need the institutions of the
good Belfast Good Friday agreement to be
up and running to demonstrate to people
that their votes count that their views
count and that democracy counts
um while I've got you we've just had the
list of ministers interests drop and I
just want to have a look at the section
from the Prime Minister Rishi Cena
because there has been some questions
about his wife's involvement in a
company called Corey kids and whether or
not there was a conflict of interest
with some of the child care Arrangements
that he's announced so in the
Declaration it says the prime minister's
wife is a venture capital investor she
owns a venture capital investment
company customer Adventures UK and a
number of direct shareholdings it then
goes on to say as the PM's set out in
his letter to the chair of the liaison
committee this includes the minority
shareholding that his wife has in
relation to the company koru kids why is
eonie declaring the one company that has
been outed in the media shouldn't he not
be declaring all of the companies that
his wife has an involvement with to
avoid any idea of a conflict of interest
I mean this I'm afraid Sophie because
this is part of an ongoing investigation
I'm not going to comment on the on this
sort of thing
when when it's when this is all over but
I'm quite sure things will be completely
clear I'm talking not specifically about
because I'm talking about why isn't he
being more
wise business dealings I think you're
being fairly specific about the Prime
Minister and his interests there's no
there's an investigation going on and
I'm going to wait to the end of that